si je l'avais su jamais ça aurait fait
j'aurais été le diamant ce président
d'une RPA de Québec remercie le ciel
d'avoir trouvé un endroit où il fait bon
vivre
ici elle ferme pas car plusieurs
résidences pour aîné peine à être
rentable dans la province 301 d'entre
elles ont mis la clé sous la porte
depuis 2021 il y a plus d'investisseurs
qui veulent investir une rentabilité de
plus en plus mince raison pour laquelle
les propriétaires de RPA interpellent le
gouvernement plutôt que de réduire les
primes covid salariales à partir du 1er
janvier 2024 tel canon C il demande
d'avoir droit à un crédit d'impôt sur la
masse à l'arrière c'est une des
solutions les plus simples à gérer c'est
une des solutions les plus efficaces à
sauver la presse écrite ça a développé
et sauver le jeu vidéo et l'intelligence
artificielle au Québec on a une masse
salariale qui est en explosion
actuellement puis on est plus capable de
supporter cette masse salariale ce
propriétaire de 14 résidences au Québec
et au Nouveau-Brunswick digne souhaité
qu'une chose continuez à donner des
soins adéquats et résidents et sans une
aide gouvernementale sur la masse
salariale et l'appréhende des décisions
difficiles dans de nombreuses autres RPA
les opérateurs
unité de soins seront seront dans
l'obligation de fermer leurs unités
parce qu'il y aura pas de support
financier avec les demandes ahurissantes
également dans ma salariale la
nourriture les coûts dans toutes les
domaines entre autres les assurances on
parle de 26 % de la population qui va
avoir au-dessus de 65 ans avec le
vieillissement de la population la
demande de soins particuliers vaguement
augmenter une combinaison qui ne fera
qu'accentuer la fragilité du secteur
selon cette copropriétaire de 6 RPA et
dans une petite résidence on est rendu
avec des masses salariales de des
millions et des millions de dollars pour
pouvoir répondre aux besoins de cette
clientèle là parce que 90% de notre
clientèle est rendu avec des soins ce
qu'il n'était pas il y a à peine 5 ans
une façon de réduire le fossé entre les
secteurs publics et privés quand les
soins et les services vont être payés ou
juste un prix partout mais les gens on
va être capable de trouver aussi une
stabilité au niveau du coût complet
l'employé
pour éventuellement qu'elle pue tant de
différence entre le public et le privé
les propriétaires de RPR seront donc
très attentifs au budget du ministre
Éric Girard le 21 mars ici Luis Simon
Lapointe Radio-Canada Québec